هل يعود ويشهد العالم ازمه عام 2008
الماليه الجواب لا طبعا بحسب خبراء بالرغم
من ان المخاوف العالميه من تداعيات انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي في الولايات المتحده
وصلت الى مصارف سويسريه ما دفع بنك الى
ابرام صفقات تاريخيه لشراء كريدي سويس
ولمنع انهيار ثاني اكبر مصرف السويسري
الذي تاسس قبل 167 عاما الحكومه السويسريه
راعت صفقه شراء هذه الحمايه النظام
المصرفي وهذه الخطوه جاءت بعد ان استفادت
طبعا سويسرا وقبلها الولايات المتحده من
تجربه الازمه الماليه العالميه التي عصفت
العالم بعام 2008 يقول هنا الخبراء
الماليين الذين شددوا على ان الازمه
الماليه الراهنه تختلف تماما عن ازمه عام
2008 لان الاسباب تختلف ايضا ولكن حاله
الهلع التي العملاء ادت الى سحب مبالغ
كبيره من المصارف مما ادى الى تراجع
البورصات وافهم المصارف في اوروبا عقب
صفقات كريدي سويس وحاله الاضطراب واضطراب
القطاع المصرفي ساهمت ايضا بهبوط اسعار
النفط الى ادنى مستوى في 15 شهرا وصمخاوف
طبعا مشاهدينا من احتمال ان تؤدي هذه
الاضطرابات الى ركود من شانه ان يؤدي الى
تراجع الطلب على النفط فضلا عن المخاوف من
رفع محتمل لاسعار الفائده وتحديدا في
الولايات المتحده هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
هذه السندات تم ايجادها كتفكره بعد
الازمه الماليه العالميه 2008
واطلق عليها
كونتينز كما
يقال عليها وكان الغرض منها هي امتصاص
الخسائر في حاله حدوث ازمات حاده كما تحدث
الان وتكون هي الجزء الاول او الفرسلاير
بامتصاص الخسائر حتى لا يتاثر المذيعين
وغيرهم من حمله السندات الاعلى المساهمين
في هذه الحاله بيتم
انخفاض راس مال الشركه الى حد كبير وهذا
الحد هو الذي
يبدا عنه
هذه السندات فبالتالي بنقول هم اللير
الاولاني او الشريحه الاولانيه هم الكوكوز
وبعد هذا ياتي المساهمين
فبالتالي ماذا حدث بقى في هذه الاسهم هذه
الاسهم من يمتلكها يمتلكها كثير جدا من
الهايبر او
المؤسسات التامين وغيرها لانها تدر عائد
بمرتفع
[موسيقى]